invité tout à l'heure du Club de la
Presse d'Europe numéro 1 Charles Pasqua
affirmait que devant le trop plein de
candidats de la majorité à l'Elysée il
n'avait pas du tout l'intention lui de
se lancer dans la course le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui par ailleurs revenu sur
son idée d'organiser des primaires il ne
faut pas confondre les primaires avec
un combat de chiffonniers je veux dire
par là que c'est
à l'heure actuelle les choses prennent
une mauvaise tournure les primaires
c'est autre chose les primaires ça
consiste à dire il n'y a pas de
candidats auto désignés autoproclamé ou
de droite divin il n'y a pas non plus un
pouvoir qui est reconnu au parti dans
chaque famille chacun a le droit de se
présenter s'il est porteurs donnaient ou
d'un projet pour la France à condition
que les règles du jeu soient bien
établies et que chacun s'y battent